can all demons together defeat muzon
which ones would pose the most threat to
him and which ones would be defeated in
a matter of seconds well firstly i think
we can all agree that normal demons
would pose no threat to muzon as they
can be easily eliminated even by amateur
demon slayers because of this let's
primarily focus on demon moons despite
being insanely powerful the 12 kizuki
would face a great deal of trouble while
battling muzon during the sunrise
countdown arc all heshira's and tonjro
combined barely succeeded in defeating
him the biggest reason they managed to
pull off such a colossal feat was due to
tamayo's help tomeo was well aware of
muzon's strength as she had spent a good
amount of time with him therefore she
came prepared with a poison strong
enough to weaken muzon significantly
allowing the hashiris to fight him in
somewhat fair conditions muzon is quite
literally invincible and if he fought
the demon slayers in his full power he
would easily obliterate them keeping
this in mind there is absolutely no way
that the demon moons could defeat him he
would probably crush them all in a
matter of minutes alright the answer to
that question was pretty obvious but
what would happen if demon moons fought
muzon in his poisoned state would it be
any different muzon isn't just powerful
in terms of physical strength he's the
king for a reason as he is the one who
created the army of demons additionally
all demons are made from muzon cells
which means that he has complete control
over them the cells act as a
double-edged sword offering great
strength to the demons but at the same
time making them vulnerable to muzon in
season two of the anime when akaza
visits muzon to inform him about the
mujin train incident the demon king is
pretty furious at him in his fury with
just one look muzon inflicted immense
damage to the poor demon for a demon as
strong as a kaza to take so much damage
with just one look speaks volumes from
muson's capabilities this basically
implies that the demon king no matter
how weakened he is by injuries or even
poison can defeat any demon in a matter
of seconds so if we wanted to make this
comparison realistic and fair we would
have to strip muzon of his ability to
control other demons only then can the
demon moons have a fair fight with the
demon king therefore let's take away the
specific ability of muzon for a second
and compare how each demon would fare
against him in a fight which ones would
be able to hold their ground and fight
for a long time and which ones would die
quickly would any of them be able to
inflict any damage on muzon at all first
of all we'll not include average demons
and lower moons in this comparison since
as we already stated they're just too
weak and wouldn't make any significant
difference in the fight the first upper
moons would be gyotora and daki the two
siblings have two advantages one is
gyotoro's blades giving him significant
crowd control over muzon's tentacles and
the other one is the fact that they need
to be decapitated at the same time in
order to kill them muzon's tentacles are
pretty strong and having the ability to
take care of them is a considerable
advantage unfortunately gyotoro lacks
speed and strength required to battle a
powerful adversary like muzon what's
more daki is his weakness and even muzon
believes that gyotaro can do much better
without her all in all both of the
siblings will be killed fairly quickly
next is upper moon 5 gyoko yoko has some
really strong abilities such as
teleportation and spawning large fish
monsters from his pots considering the
fact that gyoko has been on muzon's side
for a long time the demon king is well
aware of his tricks and techniques
joko's abilities may work on someone who
has no information about him but for the
demon king he's a piece of cake muzon
would easily destroy his pots quickly
defeating the upper moon 5 demon moving
forward the upper rank 4 also has a very
impressive skill set which might just
help him last a bit longer in a fight
against muzon than the previously
mentioned demons hontangu can manipulate
his flesh at will allowing him to
increase or decrease his size and make
clones of himself each time he is
decapitated this is a very useful skill
to possess and considering the fact that
ontango is one of the stealthiest and
fastest demons in the upper moons he
might just be able to prolong his life
against muzon and even dodge some of his
attacks as well however at the end of
the day muzon can still easily beat him
his flesh manipulation may be bothersome
but it would only mean that muzon would
have to spend a little more time
battling him what's more he doesn't
possess enough strength to actually deal
any significant damage to the demon king
alright here's where things begin to get
serious with the next challenger being
the one and only akaza the upper rank 3
would definitely pose some problems for
the demon king and let me explain why
akasa was insanely strong even as a
human and now as a demon he is on a
completely different level his sole
weakness is the selfless state ability
possessed only by a few demon slayers
this power when awakened can prevent
akaza from sensing his opponent's
fighting spirit making him useless in a
fight however this ability is unique to
the demon slayers only meaning that
muzon would not be able to hide his
presence from a kaza what's more he also
possesses the ability which allows him
to pinpoint his foes weaknesses all of
that coupled with his exceptional
martial art skills and speed would
definitely allow him to land a few blows
on muzon due to his experience and
overall much greater strength in akaza
muzon would obviously win the fight
eventually but not without a few
scratches so if akaza managed to land
some hits on muzon how would doma fare
against him it's pretty unfortunate that
we weren't shown the full extent of
doma's powers and capabilities in the
manga however based on what we have seen
doma is not to be underestimated as he
is a staggeringly powerful foe an
essential point to note is that he
doesn't really have any known weakness
this would make it much harder for muzon
to deal with him the only reason doma
lost in the manga was because of his
careless attitude and the poison he
consumed shinobu had been consuming the
wisteria flower in minor amounts for
over a year and even then doma didn't
die from absorbing her in any case he
would not have to worry about the poison
in a battle against muzon and he would
definitely not underestimate the demon
king one bit the upper rank 2 possesses
perception mobility and strength that
far surpasses those of the demons
mentioned before even his blood demon
art is quite impressive and allows him
to manipulate his flesh and blood to
create ice and frost using these
techniques doma can deal significant
damage and possibly freeze muzon
therefore he would definitely put up a
good fight and would stand his ground
the longest but would eventually lose
finally let's talk about the one who
would really give moves on a tough time
the upper moon one kokushibo now the
fight between the two would be very
interesting indeed considering how
unbelievably strong they are but that's
not the main point here the reason why
it would be pretty different from other
fights so far is kokoshibo's ability to
regenerate his head while decapitated
this power was witnessed in his fight
against the hashiris during the infinity
castle arc akasa could also regenerate
his head but i'm only mentioning
kokoshibo because akaza's regeneration
was much slower and he gave up midway on
the other hand kokoshibo managed to
fully regenerate his head in a matter of
seconds this would play a massive role
in his fight against demon king and
would mean that even when muzon
decapitates him kokoshibo will survive
and continue to fight additionally
kokoshibo is the only demon capable of
using breathing techniques which makes
him all the more dangerous his moon
breathing combined with impeccable
swordsmanship would give muzon a pretty
tough time a point to note about his
regenerative abilities is that he only
managed to regenerate his head once
during the fight with the shiras he may
be able to do it multiple times but we
can't be sure of that therefore if
muslin slashes his head multiple times
he would probably not be able to recover
in time and ultimately the fight would
end in the demon king's favor but it
would definitely take some time and now
the final question what if all upper
moons fought him together in general
each upper moon is usually as strong as
a hashira some of them are even more
powerful comparable to the strength of
two or more pillars even shinobu agreed
with this statement therefore we can say
that this would be similar to muzon
fighting a dozen hashiras at the same
time which is more than he fought during
the sunrise countdown arc this would be
the greatest battle of all demon slayer
history and muzon will not be able to
get out of this one easily the fight
would be much longer with all seven of
the upper moon demons working together
gradually weakening the demon lord and
tiring him out the upper moons would be
at a significant advantage due to their
strength and unique abilities which they
can combine to inflict massive damage on
muzon at the very beginning of the fight
the demon king would act quickly to take
care of the weaker upper moons like yoko
daki and yuutaro before they are killed
gyoko and kyotaro would use their
special poisoning techniques on muzon it
wouldn't do much at the time but in the
long run it may weaken him a bit
furthermore as time goes on akaza and
kokoshiba would deal a lot of physical
damage to muzon at the same time domo
would use his powerful blood demon art
and the powdered ice to poison muzon
even more the fight would begin to wear
the demon king down weakening him to the
point that the upper moons now have a
slight advantage over him eventually
near the end of the night the upper
moons would have wounded him enough to
decapitate him and the one to do it
would be none other than the strongest
of them all kogoshibo however let's not
forget that muzon is capable of
regenerating his head making him immune
to death by decapitation although he
wouldn't die regenerating his head would
wear down muzon considerably making it
extremely hard for him to kill the
remaining demons the battle would
eventually come to an end with the sun
rising and burning all the demons
including muzon to ashes therefore the
end of this incredibly long and
impressive fight would be a tie and none
of them would be standing victorious at
the end click on this video where we
explained what would happen if yurishi
became a demon don't be shy click it